pretty wet out here we're going to
Hershey Pennsylvania tonight we have a
big rally a lot of people tremendous
lines great enthusiasm there's never
been this enthusiasm in my opinion for
the Republican Party the Republicans
have stuck together there's a witch-hunt
it's a terrible thing but even the
Democrats they couldn't find very much
because they put up two articles that
frankly a very weak and they're very
weak also they approved today of all
days we've been waiting a year and they
approved today the US MTA and I call
that the silver lining to impeachment
because without the impeachment they
would have never approved it in my
opinion the impeachment is the reason
they approved it and interestingly one
hour after the news conference they went
out into the news conference on the big
trade deal the great tracheae one of the
greatest trade deals ever made for our
country and the reason is they wanted to
muffle down the impeachment because
they're embarrassed by it and they
couldn't get the votes and that's
exactly what happened so it's a terrible
thing when they do something like that
but now it goes to I guess a vote and I
assume they will probably have to have
the votes they're very weak articles but
very importantly today we get us MCA and
that's going to be a great thing for our
farmers or manufacturers for our for
just about everybody that's good for
everybody
unions included I spoke with Richard
Trumka I spoke to James Hoffa and we had
the good talks that the Union people I
did that a few days ago we had some very
good talks and everybody is really
loving the US MCA so
very happy about that very very happy
[Music]
there's what
[Music]
well I think the Democrats I can't
imagine they vote for it because we did
nothing wrong there was absolutely
nothing done wrong they've analyzed my
conversation every way you can and when
you talk about you know the word favor
was mentioned that it was mentioned not
me a favor
you just saw the way it was and it was
nothing to do with me this has to do
with the United States the word was us
can you do us a favor than we talk about
the country and we talk about seeing the
Attorney General of the United States
when you look at it and that was just a
part of it it was a congratulatory call
and they were two of them nobody even
mentions the other one we had another
one where they won originally he won the
election and I think it's a disgrace
that people can make him Beach man out
of nothing that was a perfect
conversation if you look at Mark Levine
he analyzed the conversation one of the
great constitutional lawyers many of
them have they were perfect
conversations there's nothing to a beach
on and I think it's a disgrace I think
it's an absolute I think it's an
absolute disgrace so let's say they vote
on it I don't know when they're gonna
vote who knows all I know is they were
very embarrassed by it
and that's why they brought up USMC a an
hour after because they figure it'll
buffle it a little bit and if you look
at if you look at the poll numbers the
firehouse poll just came out and we're
way ahead of everybody in every state
every you know most of the I think most
of the swing states we're way ahead and
you know what I don't know if that's
impeachment or the fact that we have the
best economic numbers that we've ever
had in our country have the best
unemployment numbers and employment
numbers we have the best numbers we've
ever had in our country and so I think
that has something to do with it you saw
on Friday 266 thousand jobs new job
and other countries all over the world
they're not doing well we're doing great
you know Jesse I I'm amazing I listen to
this and he just is out there he punches
counter punches he slam and he doesn't
stop but at some point do you think from
my perspective it's like he's just
flooding the zone
there's no fact-checking he just gets
away and people buy it especially on the
right-wing media he's praising Mark
Levin I don't see anything wrong with
that okay I think of him being on
offense as effective and he's got to
speak the truth he's a great promoter of
himself and the campaign and the
Republican Party and no one does it
better than he does so that's fine I
think Democrats like you maybe are
frustrated because he's such an eloquent
speaker and so precise with his
combative pronunciations and
denunciations that your head is spinning
and they just frustrates you and it must
be frustrating because here's the deal
if the economy was in the gutter and
this country was sad and there was
terrorist attacks and there was a
horrible war impeachment would be really
really hot and people would be ready to
short-circuit this guy early but it's
not things are great and so for them to
do this now and pull the chain look
super petty and everybody knows it well
I think that would mean it was a
political thing if the economy was the
issue as opposed to what they're
alleging which is abuse of power and
obstruction looks partisan okay all
right Dana how did you react to the
president's statement well I think it he
has to be on offense I mean what's the
alternative is to sit there and be
punched in the face on impeachment the
whole time and one that's just not in
his nature it's also not good politics
he has a country to run as
commander-in-chief but he's also got an
election to try to win he can't take any
vote for granted that's why he's out
there doing these rallies and he has to
go to these places like Pennsylvania
Wisconsin and Michigan and if I you know
he's gonna press his advantage there and
he should all right Greg I have to
apologize but I'll say one thing I don't
think he could have exited this in a
better situation with a great economy
with a really weak these two articles of
impeachment
he's got John I mean you should be very
happy right now he's gonna have a great
rally yeah well he's gonna have a big
rally in Pennsylvania and you can watch
I think right here on
Fox News Channel